live hold on what is wrong with okay
yeah there we go restream works
perfect long Dev day
yesterday we got some cool stuff to do
today
um I'll start by saying that this
article is now public posted it this
morning it's gotten a little bit of
attention so far just posted a few hours
ago uh I actually added quite a bit more
stuff to this since yesterday so there's
now sticky actions considered harmful
with evidence from the original paper
itself so result doesn't follow what was
claimed there's evidence with uh
experimental evidence with 300 runs of
carbs hyper
sweep and then there's also you can just
play the game and see that this is
obviously true I put this thing together
you can play the game it's really
freaking hard with sticky
actions there you go and then there are
a bunch of there's a bunch of discussion
stuff down
here so
anyways um what I'm going to do
today we're going to do probably a
little bit of stuff on the
Moa mostly just experiment Al side stuff
we're probably going to do a little bit
on Atari queuing up some new uh some new
jobs given that well given how this is
gone we might do a little bit of looking
into carbs as well uh this hyper Prem
sweep that I'm using is better than
everything else but you know it could
still be improved there's still some
settings that we can make a little bit
better
here and yeah we're going to go from
there
so anyways uh let's start on
that oh and uh yeah I let this sweep
keep running just uh just in case it
found anything
cool let's see if it found
anything
no no not really didn't find anything
good so yeah now that's 300 experiments
of pong without finding a single good
run with sticky
yeah so this run we can kill
this we're done with that
um I'm kind of wondering whether I want
to
include this repeat action prob as a
parameter and just set the default value
to
zero actually we'll we'll look at that
in a little bit that's one of the things
I wanted to do with carbs for sure is I
wanted to change the way that we set
default hyper parameters uh so that
carbs explores around those defaults so
I think what we want to do is we're
going to want to have for future
experiments since because I found all
this stuff on Atari right and now I want
to run like a nice big sweep on Atari so
that we can actually get some really
awes awesome uh policies that train very
fast a nice new set of benchmarks on
Atari uh by the way pong trains in 3
minutes with uh without sticky actions
so uh that's cool we actually got it to
be super
fast and pretty sample efficient as well
pretty sample
efficient um so we're going to mess with
carbs in a bit I think that we yeah
let's start actually with um there's a
different run that it's going to be
easier for us to look at
hold
on I have too many
windows this
it yeah yeah yeah this is it so let me
show what I did with the Moa since I
know that's what a lot of people are
interested
in so I added uh some hyper parameters
from the sweep right
hypers I added uh hypers into the The
Sweep args as well like this no big deal
there status
[Music]
upper this is for the mini
DOTA it's ocean
let me just diff this because there was
one important
fix right here uh I wasn't respawning
the towers
correctly before which is why stuff was
getting stuck once I fixed this The
Sweep started working way
better and then I believe there's one
other thing in the mobile
file yeah I just uncommented total
Towers taken all right
let's just uh commit all these because
these are nice
changes and I should probably move my
camera as well I I moved it before oddly
but this is kind of awkward the way I
have it here for de for development I
did this for the
article so let's just move
this and then I will move
myself over to
here and yeah I have my camera flipped
this way which is
cool so now I don't have uh code covered
uh the chat covering code or whatever uh
we're going to need to go grab the file
for this as well I uh I'll show you the
experiment was a fun experiment so we
did a 5 billion step training Run for
the mooba how long did this
take 4 hours 35 minutes not
terrible was running at what's
this only 300,000 steps per second is a
little bit
suspicious I guess we'll look at the
hyper prameters but um you know it's
pretty much
linear we get up to close to 100 Towers
taken over uh the course of the run so
it's 100 uh Towers per environment taken
and I have I think 1,200 copies of the
environment or something so know it's
doing lots of games definitely doing
lots of games
and do we have any interesting reward
curves
here nothing
insane we'll see if we get something
cool out of this at the very least I
mean it's definitely taking Tower so it
should be doing
something I think we don't have like the
full logs in this version yet but uh
this will be a nice a nice starting
point
is
this is this
updated yeah there we
go sometimes it get
stuck
kilobytes is all it takes for AI
model so let's see I'm hoping that this
is going to do something interesting in
the
Moa we will
see mode
eval
human eval model path
MOA and we're probably going to want to
run this the high level
first just to
see I don't know what other settings I
have in place
so they are fighting some stuff over
here
there are a couple agents that are going
down
mid what are the rest of them
doing hold
right I would expect to at least have a
reasonably decent policy by now
[Music]
and I don't want to append the
frame
okay so let's see what these guys are
doing and then we'll watch them
we have on the red side we've got two of
them that are two of the agents that are
pretty
consistently running it down
mid we have one blue agent that's kind
of farming
neutrals but he's getting in over his
head I don't know why we'd have anybody
like just Meandering around spawn though
especially with a policy that's been
trained this
long and with Towers being taken as
well let me make sure that we actually
got it
PT make sure that we're actually loading
it right
eval model
path yeah this should be
fine so that's kind of
weird I'm a bit disappointed I was
expecting something substantially
better it should not be particularly
hard to learn to run down uh down mid or
whatever it's possible that it started
getting worse over over
time right like why doesn't it just go
straight down
mid they do sort of meander over so like
this will eventually cause the wave
balance to shift and have you know
Towers be
taken they're very uh finicky
though let's see uh what the
let's see what the graphs look like
maybe we can learn
something it looks like it's getting
better up until here and then something
happens
death reward distance goes
down
H this is quite odd the way that this is
so the cyclical thing is fine it's
cyclical like this because the uh
because like games get reset that's
normal so possibly still not great
though
here wait how many towers do we expect
to be taken
hold on I think that we might have just
not run this correctly cuz in a
billion we get 24 in a billion I thought
our sweep was better than
that let's go check the hyper parameter
sweep that we did for
this welcome YouTube
folks uh no not this one we've already
beaten that one to
death
um where's
sweeps this
one
yeah
so total Towers taken here
right and we took this one here yeah so
this one at one 1 billion steps has 50
Towers
taken so this does not match the result
that we just
got cuz I grabbed the hyper parameters
from this curve here hold on let me make
this larger so you can see
larger this one this is the experiment
we based it off of which is this point
here I believe
and Norm reward is not great but
here we've got this nice steep curve and
this dire level looks
good does reward XP does seem to be
going up over time though it does go
down later
on but reward
overall
here oh this is an entropy
crash yeah this is not
good how does this policy do so well
with crashed
crazy according to this somehow lots of
towers are being
taken with crashed entropy
which does not make sense to
me so yeah this is not actually a great
set of hyper parameters and like
whatever we're doing for our eval
Criterion is probably
screwy um is this like a particularly
fast
run this trains at 600,000 steps per
second so if it's just running the game
faster that will also lead to the creeps
taking more Towers right
XP now it's funny to me that we actually
do
see this like reward
total Towers taken is
here 1.2 billion
run do we see anything that matches that
over
here oh it's very
low okay so there's um yeah there's
absolutely a problem in selecting which
run then
because whatever we did here did not uh
did not get us the good
run this Tower's taken metric is no
good what about this run this has like a
really steep reward curve or XP
curve this is a very short run it only
is 400 seconds which
is let's do agent steps
no this is about the same
speed just a very short
run reward Tower goes up goes back
down Norm reward starts to go
up distance does start going back down
this is where you want it to
be reward death goes down goes back up
oh and then the overall reward is going
up like this
nicely entropy is low but not fully
crashed that is still very very low
it's kind of weird to me that Towers
taken doesn't end up being a great
metric
right so Towers taken should tell you
how quickly it's it's
learning or
no right like if the minions are doing
stuff to help their team you'd see more
Towers being taken
though I guess if both teams are just
running down mid then that's not going
to help you
XP though this is going to have the
effect of just picking you know whatever
one sets its own reward weight
curve I mean so they probably only play
like a game
here five Towers
why is this Norm reward metric so noisy
as well it's like crazy
noisy I guess it's cuz you're getting
reward Tower in
here I guess that's probably spiking it
a
bunch
rate The Hope here is to figure out
um a reasonable sweet metric I can use
to get better policies out of this we
can watch it play to see if it's
actually doing anything remotely
interesting in human mode I doubt it
is I don't remember having Mouse control
in this branch of the code
um well it kind of already does that I
will explain how in a second so we have
a puffer that's like come to Mid with us
to
fight yeah my skills don't work here
right yeah yeah yeah this is the old
version I forgot that we even had
I guess we are in the right Branch
though so here's the thing um carbs
already takes time into
account
so if I just give it the metric of total
Towers taken like obviously the longer
you run it the more Towers it takes
right but like carbs will look at your
run and look how long it took it took
you to get that many towers and it will
consider all runs for which there exist
no other runs that are both faster and
have more towers does that make
sense carbs creates like this parito
optimal Frontier where it looks for it's
looking for Towers but it's also looking
for fast runs at the same time so yeah
normally you'd be right um but because
of uh carbs we should not need to do
that this is not actually the reward
given this is they're not getting
rewarded for total Towers taken it's
just carbs is using this to select hyper
parameters it is very weird to me though
that like
the thing we just saw registers is
taking a lot of
towers I mean I guess technically a
couple of them go down mid but is that
really all that you need this looks way
better here so this one this gets to
like six XP so they're fighting a lot
there right and then if we look at like
this one here this is the run that we
used yeah this is Tiny like really low
XP
reward are they all like
this what about this one
here there's another point or is this
totally
different nope same
thing so that's really
weird we have multiple different runs
here that have fully crashed
entropy mind you this is the Moa not
Atari I checked a entropy crash with
Atari we're fine
there performance SL remaining
we're going to figure this out also and
then we're going to do like some carb
stuff that's going to help everything uh
this article in case folks haven't seen
it um this article is
live we found a really big thing about
Atari this is on X if you're
interested uh where's where did our tab
go
runs and we can clearly see which of
these are getting
XP they all go up and then back down as
well
how steep is the towers taking curve on
this one let me see this one
says this one says 5 and 250 mil
garbage this one somehow
has like 10 and two 50 mil so this one
thinks it's twice as
good it's very weird and it can't
possibly be twice as good because of how
quickly entropy
crashes and value loss is
insane I wonder if this is telling us
that like more Towers get taken when the
minions just do their
thing versus when they're actively like
trying to
cuz yeah that would make sense I
guess so what do we do instead reward
XP or normal norz like XP something like
that are there any runs that could get
good normalized
reward maybe that's a
thing like there kind of
are what's this
run on a 250 million step
run that gets good Towers taken and
starts getting good
weird I'm going to try to download this
one but I don't think this is the
correct
file oh well it just has a parquette
file anyways
right yeah I guess there's nothing
there can I not refresh
what this thing just
like did it just switch my color
scheme that was
weird yeah okay so there's no model file
for this yeah I remember I didn't save
model files for um for sweeps to prevent
blowing up
storage so bizarre though
entropy this low is never good you
always want it to hover at least like
around like here you
know yeah and the value loss explodes
here so it's really it's only good until
about 150
mil wait as the value loss is exploding
it's getting more XP
that doesn't make sense
right something very odd is going
on for sure something very odd is going
on
um this what you have to deal with in
reinforcement learning
right so I guess to summarize what I'm
trying to do today there're to sort of
there are a couple different things I
want to do um I think carbs has been
really good but there are a few places
where it could be a bit better so I want
to have a better way to set the default
uh the default hyper parameters that
carbs explores starting from like using
as a starting point I want to be able to
be more specific about that I think that
will help with Atari that will help with
this that will just help with everything
um I want to run a nice Atari sweep
given that we found uh we found some
like really good pong settings yesterday
after we got rid of the sticky
actions so now um I want to run it on at
least the original Atari 7 to see how
well we do because it seems very likely
that we'll do a lot
better yeah I
have actually do I have this
here okay this is really small but uh I
did I added this pong
thing right and it's really hard to play
with sticky
actions like the padle just kind of
slides all over and I have to just kind
of get lucky that it goes sort of where
I want it to
go see it just slid way
past so uh I think we're going to do
some hyper parameter sweeps with the
other
Ms I don't actually know if I've even
been able to get a point with the sticky
actions on it's very difficult
anyways um Atari M's MOA uh the one
thing we need to do for the Moa today
really is just to figure out the reward
function a little
better and think about
that it's very odd to me how all these
metrics that all the metrics that look
good
have this really low
entropy now wait a second if they're
just chilling at spawn they can't be
leveling up right that's
impossible so despite this low entropy
they have to be doing
here and how are they doing anything
with the value loss like this do have
policy
loss policy loss is actually low and K
is
then the value loss starts
hm reward XP wait okay reward XP is
allowed to decrease after this so right
here this downfall here this is like the
first set of games finishing so this is
actually a very nice reward
curve for
this and then this normal reward is too
noisy to use I believe
right can you even smooth something that
looks like
that what happens if I just do this
awkward maybe could reward hero damage
to
Towers
um so I think that this has the same
potential problem as Towers
taken like you might be a little bit
like you might be right that that's a
little bit better but the thing is if
you're training if the agents get better
then both teams are getting better right
so they're fighting in the middle so if
you have two agents if they're fighting
each other in the middle then like
that's good but it's kind of hard for
them to do any damage to Towers because
they're being defended
against
right the actual solution to this
problem for reference is Elo but I'm
being lazy and I don't want to do ELO
just yet because ELO's a really big pain
in the ass to do correctly
though I'm going to need to do it at
some point just today ain't the day
maybe next week I come back you know
more better rested for something like
that but that's going to take a fair bit
of
effort I mean
XP they can still fight over waves right
I kind of like this reward XP
thing though it's a little bit obnoxious
how it's like all these metrics are
graphs I mean I kind of have XP graphs
on some of the longer runs like maybe
some of these are okay they're all cylic
though
it still doesn't track completely in my
head that like the most worthless one
should
be Towers taken like this does this one
say that it's leveling
up no this one doesn't even say it's
leveling
level why does it keep getting smaller
over
time oh no that might actually be
reasonable the games need to get offset
properly I guess like I think what's
happening here is that all the games
they start at the same
time
I could try to smooth these curves
out this would do give us better data it
will make these environment potentially
take quite a long time to initialize
though right because
like the problem here is that you start
all the games at the same time so if
you'll notice this is actually like
these Peaks are getting smoothed over
time um but what's happening is cuz all
the games are synced up like they're all
in the early game then they're all in
the mid game then they're all in the
late game and then some of them reset
and they'll start to get offset over
time cuz not all the games are going to
be the same exact length but that takes
a really long time the normal fix to
this is that you just step all the M's a
random amount at the start when you
initialize them
um but like dota's 15,000 step games or
whatever at
least yeah that could take a long
time I mean I could initialize level
level and towers stuff randomly at the
start I
guess definitely have to do something
about
that cuz all these graphs being cyclical
is going to make a big problem for hyper
Prem sweeps right you
totally okay so for now I just need to
figure out what metric I want to
optimize that's going to be like
reasonably stable
games probably good
enough doesn't have the problem from
before where like cuz if they're going
to go fight each other in the center
they'll still get XP off of waves and
stuff yeah let's let's probably do uh
let's do
that that totally makes sense let me
just do that um
okay that'll at least get us a starting
point for this and then we'll do so
we'll do that we'll start on the other
stuff with carbs we'll launch both
sweeps and then I'll see what I do after
that
level level equals player.
Lev if player.
level is greater than
level just do that self. total levels
gained Plus =
1 right so we'll just keep track of the
total levels
gained this gets initialized to zero so
this gets initialized to
easy
okay so now we have a reasonable metric
for this
now I have to figure out what I want to
do about
carbs so they're kind of two separate
problems I think with carbs um it has
these really wonky search
patterns like let me look at
pong it's a very good algorithm by the
way so I'm going to stand by this for
use in this like this article um it's
been outperforming everything else by a
mile so
improvements from here are just good all
around but yeah it's
like you see it like it it does some
stuff and then it stops for a while and
then it does some stuff it stops for a
while and then it does some
stuff how big does it think the parito
front is on
this episode return um
um
time is onei
stuck and explain what this parito front
means in a second though it'll be very
obvious from the
graph here it
is okay
so this is
the Paro front so what this means is
that for every point on the line
here there does not exist a
point that is um
farther to the left or farther
up and that means that there's no run
that achieved this score or better while
being just as fast or
faster so there can be runs that are
better than this run like these there
can be runs that are faster than the
this run like these over here but not
both so this Paro front right here is
this point
here this point
here I think this point
here maybe like here
here decent number of
points it's like what like 10 15 points
maybe on the parito
front so what carbs is supposedly doing
is it will like go through this parito
front and it'll do it'll spawn more runs
off of
that essentially
so let me see if I go back to the
original graph if I can figure out what
it's
doing oh I could also do here I could do
instead of return I can do this can be
uptime so I can see how long of
experiments it's running over the over
time
interesting
so it
[Music]
ran some short
experiments a lot of short
experiments and then it ran these long
experiments that didn't
work am I reading that right and then it
ran shorter
ones why would it do
well all right this is a full
run and look at this this is a full run
that's just like not doing very well at
all it's kind of going up
but so why why is it doing that
I'm trying to figure out what it's
looking
for so carbs is supposed to search
starting from Paro optimal points
there shouldn't be any parito optimal
points that take a really long time and
get very low return
issue
nope sad
really want to fix this today like if we
can get carbs to give us proper hyper
parameters we will be in a a very good
spot hold on I be right
um this pretty confusing here I had to
note one thing down real
quick so the Hope here is if we can
figure out how to get
carbs to be more
consistent is there a set of hyper
parameters that's like close to this
I mean if it's doing a whole block like
this
right I think there's something weird
with the way it's making the
suggestions there should be more Paro
optimal
points it shouldn't just be
sampling I mean I'm assuming these are
very similar hyper parameters I could be
totally wrong here right let's do like
filter episode reward less than equal to
like
runs and then we'll do created Tim stamp
as well so we'll just like so this is
wait what's the time stamp
it's
August 1st 1653
p.m. wait is that
18 y
work 8 August 1st
1816 should be
refresh okay yeah so here are all these
similar runs right
huh I caught
them do you see how they're
like it's rerunning the exact same
thing do you see
this so it's retrying the same thing too
many damn
times and then this one is just one
trial
okay so there's some weird retry thing
happening
here it shouldn't be able to do
this yeah it should not be able to be
doing
this so still a good algorithm right um
all of our experiments are
intact all of our results are intact
it's just uh it doesn't occasionally get
stuck for a
while we still have good hyper Prem
sweeps if anything we are going to get
better results after but this is still
beating basian every time even with this
probably ridiculously good at once we
fix
this okay I'm going to go commit the
Atari changes that we made
where is
it here
no we look at the demo first so I have a
couple ideas on why this could be
happening
idea the way carbs works you have this
carbs object right and it's
stateful so it gives you a suggestion
like this
we copy the
suggestion we
um put the suggestion into the prams we
use and then we update
carbs like
this and I'm pretty sure that if you
don't do this I'm pretty sure if if you
miss this step here then it will give
you um the same parameters
we get our
[Music]
suggestions are you sure you want to
pass the original
suggestion I think
so as it to the rounded to the powers
suggestions
um if I recall I think it screws up
carbs if you like modify the suggestion
that's why I did that
copy I'm pretty sure it screws it up if
you modify the
suggestion I mean clearly like this is
you see what's happening oh wait you
don't see what's happening here because
the chat's over it hold on it it's kind
of obvious when you look at it with uh
the full
graph
so welcome re as well the the full
article is
up uh I actually added some stuff so
there's some more to it
now from yesterday but
here so what I did here is I went to
this is like a weird regime of the
sweep there like just a a space where it
did a whole bunch of runs that got
really low
perf and if you look at just these runs
you can see that there are only three
lines here this one is a single run but
then these ones right they all pass
through the same points meaning they
have exactly the same hyper parameters
but they fan out and they're like 40
runs here you can
see so it's it's like repeatedly
suggesting the same set of hyper
parameters for some reason I think that
the most likely thing is that somehow
we're not updating it correctly with the
results so it like it thinks that it
hasn't run it
yet oh wait we get these observed values
here right
and if we don't get the observe values
then there's something
wrong but looks like it's pretty
consistently getting a whole bunch of
them
to be fair I'm not super sure that I
like the way that we're doing the
observed values at the
moment I would think that some point
here we're going to see like that it
hasn't computed the observe values so
it's just not updated carbs so it just
like keeps running the same trial but
I'm not seeing it
um the other thing thing is it's it is
possible that there's a quirk in carbs
itself so is
possible or maybe re's right and I
somehow screwed up the way that I'm uh
updating it I have to look at that
you can see we have observed values here
as
well okay so not seeing anything
here not seeing anything at all
here
um if we look at
this I can filter I can take these
filters off
this I only really see one spot where it
looks likely that it's doing this
right I don't really get how carbs
handles this basis okay well let's look
cuz maybe I've missed
for log spaces they just don't return
base two at all yeah no they don't
return base 2 that so the log space it
just means that the samples are
logarithmically spaced right so
like it that means that you're equally
likely to get something that is twice as
large as twice as
small that's what that means so instead
of you being equally likely to get
anything from like 1 to 10
right like if you if you Center your
thing at five with a linear space then
you're going to get like one away is
going to be uh five then two away is
going to be six three away is going to
be seven so that's how it structures
that
distribution with the log space it's
like two away or
whatever two and then four and then you
know it's going to be like
half well I guess not two and then four
it would be 5 10 20 and then like 2.5
1.25 so that's how it's going to
sample now mind you we're not getting
just close hyper parameters we're
getting exactly the same hyper
parameters here straight
up welcome to all the YouTube
folks currently trying to fix this hyper
parameter sweep
[Music]
Shenanigans we also have a cool art
article from today I'll put this in the
chat just cuz um this was a big
finding I know not everybody does
uh even though it's very common hold on
where yeah not everybody does
X Twitter I was thinking I could make a
video on it on the channel I don't know
would that be useful just to make like a
short little video going through this
post for the main Channel
yeah thanks uh this is this is a big
find for sure like completely screwing
up learning of a basic environment is a
big deal and it's the funny thing about
this to me is like researchers need like
researchers that use games for their
research really need to play the games
right because
like all you have to do in order to find
this bug without looking at any of the
math is you just try to play Pong for a
few minutes right with your sticky
actions and you see that I can't do
anything because like the paddle is just
going all over the place and like it's
really hard for me to control it um cuz
like it's not actually moving where I
want it to it's like randomly see it
just moved too
far cuz the sticky actions get in the
way and you're basically just relying on
getting lucky that you're in the right
spot at the the right time I'm actually
kind of amazed that RL does as well as
it does with this this is like
ridiculously
hard I don't know if I've gotten a point
on it with um with sticky actions on
without frame Skip and with like
reasonable
settings I got I think I got five points
with frame skip I think I got like one
or two points and then I haven't been
able to do anything with the with carbs
like this cuz like the pong is you're
really like reliant on like hitting it
back fast at like a hard angle to outdo
the the AI and like that requires
precise control like I can't even get
the ball even knowing where it's going
to be I'm like relying on like getting
lucky okay there I got one point on on
it finally but yeah there you go
let's go back to hyper prams the cool
thing is once we figure this out once we
have carbs like Rock Solid we're going
to do full sweeps on everything why
don't you post this finding on archive
or somewhere more researchers will see
all the researchers are on Twitter these
days that's the thing Twitter's like
actually the best spot for this stuff um
and
like I'm no longer in Academia time it
takes me to write this stuff up for AR
archive versus number of people that
will see
it not worth
it really really not worth it like
better chance that I get people to see
it here
frankly like I don't know I've been
doing more stuff on X lately and this is
not small for reinforcement learning
right like the biggest accounts in RL
that I know of are like 10K so this is
actually a sizable portion of the RL
audience here
how many hyper parameters can you
feasibly tune I don't know all of
them like imbu does all of them for
procgen it does seem to scale pretty
well with number of hyper parameters
though if you have like a really fiddly
hyper parameter that's like uh you know
oddly correlated or has weird
interactions with the other ones that
can be difficult to discover
I do have one thing on um I did post the
puffer paper though um green on
archive yeah I mean high dimensionality
is a problem yeah so this is on
archive
right well there a lot of work to do
those
um always get warnings about high yeah
there is a warning in
carbs that you're sweeping a lot of them
um I mean I talked to the guys at in
bu a few weeks ago and they told me like
hey if you've got compute for it just
throw everything at
it though they did also say to seed it
with more random samples so maybe we
should do that but I think the problem
we're seeing here is not
related the problem that we're seeing
here is hold on let me get this to look
sane
again like this is these are exact
duplicate hyper parameters here that are
producing this oh yeah what I wanted to
do was I wanted to crop
this what happened
created greater than
whoops what if you only have one
490 well I mean I'm using two 490s so
I'm not doing that much better with this
because I have the rest of the cluster
allocated to other
projects um and if you only have 1490
then you'll be very happy to know that
these experiments run in like 3 to 10
minutes each
isn't that nice Atari experiments in
like 3 to 10 minutes
um I don't think you ever really want to
do grid search right you want to do
random search if anything
644 really I use
minari I wouldn't be surprised if puffer
with Atari is faster than whatever you
have with minari
you can also just use puffer with minari
and have that be fast if you'd
like here I'll show you the the times on
these
so I'm going to move my picture back
over here for now so I can do
return uh these is steps steps is not
really useful
right but if I do relative time process
time and let's say I
do the best runs which are like the good
runs mind you this is the dumb Sweep
with um sticky actions on the other one
is the exact same time it's just better
wand
B come on W B fine I'll load up the
better sweep
sweep all right here minutes right 2 to
minutes and these experiments range from
how many steps I think it's 5 to 25
it solves the environment right
change okay it looks like we did between
uh five and like 15 mil for most of
these
runs and they run so 5 million steps
looks like it runs in like 3 minutes or
so
it's like 30 40,000 steps per second
training with
Atari I believe like the S sp3d faults
and stuff are like 3,000 or something
ah so as I expected again
right there all one set of hyper
something definitely happened that
removed
right so we can now see exactly what has
happened and the funny thing about this
is we actually know that hang on
1940 yeah look do you see how like few
runs there are
here the vast majority of these are just
like fans
they just like fan out into
this there's 116 runs but they're like
barely
any which is weird because
like we actually have nice hyper
parameter
coverage at the start we
do we can see it right here right this
is where it happens or whatever
and somehow
the optimal ones get kicked
up is
better this is
true resample
frequency and num random
samples let me go check
um let me go check on
carbs yo for the YouTube folks that
actually though would it be useful for
me to like some of these like better
articles that I actually put time into
would it be useful me for me to just
like post me going through them on
YouTube I don't know what the overlap is
between the YouTube and the X audience I
assume it's not huge
effort I'd probably watch I mean I
figure that like I like I know that I
personally I don't read a lot of long
form articles cuz I'm always doing stuff
but like I will if I have something that
I can just leave on my phone I will
listen to something you know while I'm
doing other stuff
so I'm I might just make one of those
because that would only take me like you
know that would take me like an hour to
make and then I'll just see how it does
viewership wise
carbs
[Music]
perams set better Direction
size
Max
wait set better Direction size Max
suggestion cost and WB params for your
run I'm not aware of any situation in
which we should change the other
parameters
really wait resample a Paro
point every n
observations set zero to
disable oh this is kind of cool actually
weirdly
enough I basically copied your demo and
the duplicate prams is not happening it
doesn't always
happen doesn't always happen and you
also did you do the same thing that I
did you have to like zoom in on little
Windows of parameters basically because
like you get tons of suggestions at the
start and then it can collapse later on
observations num candidates
for suggestion per
dim should just go show up it and VI and
be like hey fix
so okay there are a couple suspicious
things in here I
guess but not really because resample
Paro
point that doesn't seem like it should
be
necessary okay so
Define
suggestion so we frequency is not
greater than
zero so we get here we get generate
candidate does the WB logging enable
flag work I don't know I haven't played
with it I think that they graph like uh
they have separate graphs that they
output if you want to play with it and
uh you find something cool though I'd be
happy to add
it as long as it doesn't spam tons of
data this is all just in the dev branch
of puffer
accepting puffer
doing not amazing but not
terrible
yeah it's so funny how my worst post has
done the
best
whatever quite happy with puffer though
we're
at 716
that's
here why is there no remember
suggestion
wait remember
suggestion if is suggestion
remembered is
suggestion this is a pram here which is
true by
default so is it not remembering
suggestions well callcore generate
candidates
what's this
do get surrogate
model do fit
observations do fit
suggestions do fit
failures fit failures I got to see what
it does with failures as well
conservative that's
fine all parito
observations fit parito set of all the
observations okay so this is why it
takes a few seconds per suggestions it's
doing all these model calls this is a
learned
model it's just like an sklearn
some sort of gaussian or whatever
thingy uh numb samples to generate you
see here this is going to generate by
default 100 suggestions per hyper
parameter so this should be a whole
bunch of
suggestions probabil sample around
origins in
basic origins in basic
so
weird do rounding
first this is why we overgeneration so
there is a
mask I don't think it would ever be
masking out everything though that would
be weird
right the question is do this suggestion
get remembered ever
Jesus there's a lot of stuff
here so the only thing we need to figure
out is whether this actually gets
remembered anywhere
right I don't see anywhere that this is
getting
stored I think generate candidates
as the name implies just generates the
candidates and doesn't store
them and then you're reliant
on other stuff for that okay let's go
off of that
assumption so this suggest function is
going to give
us a new set of
points
and it only is going to remember
if you suggest a hold
on this is just for
resampling it remembers
here so
otherwise oh no it's down here there's a
suggestion remembered
right because you're going to get
generate
candidate we didn't see any error
generating candidate warning messages we
get suggestion and basic
none on
this it's going to give us our suggested
parameter and then it's going to
remember it
observe forget
suggestion add observation
get observation
log
add add
observation so it adds it to success
observations
resample we specifically want the
non-conservative version so we can
resample ordering will determine which
we suggest we search first one that has
the minimum
number of observations suggestions
already okay so it gives you uh exactly
the same as what's in the Paro front
Okay it's not suggesting
around that which is that's
fine I'm stumped here I do not know why
this
is behaving this
way um I'm trying to think if there's
like test I can set up that will catch
this if there's any smart way I can do
this instead of just staring at the code
I mean I could run a bunch of really
short
trials I would still take a
while there's no log file for this
somewhere is
okay let's figure out what model this
is I think that this is not what we want
I think that this is just the
uh here there's an easy way to just
figure this
out I was hoping it would be some log
checkpoint path yeah it's just saving
the
um oh wait
no this actually might be good do you
see it saving the success
observations this is actually what we
this is good okay we got lucky
guys we got lucky
okay I always forget this is I don't
need that okay so here we have the
configuration nothing fancy
think 300 success
observations which is what we'd expect
right because why would they be
suggestions one outstanding
suggestion and resample count is going
to be zero but we'll check just in
case an
INT zero okay so let's see what the
outstanding suggestion is
I bet you if we just click one of
these it's going to be the same thing
pram I can't tell if these are bases or
something
right uh okay it's actually kind of hard
to tell with that one
what
about frame skip is lens
based
four I think this is frame skip four and
then what's the next
one learning
rate there any of these that I can see
that are
like I'm just looking if I can match
basically the idea is I'm trying to see
if it's the outstanding suggestion is
the same as like the con uh the DI like
the collapse suggestion that makes sense
I'm going to have to count though right
[Music]
so
one
two
three
four
five five
back right
3675 for Max grad
Norm this match
distribution 0.53 this is
different there's no 0.53 here
right
yeah so maybe this is not the collapse
suggestion though it did look like there
was one outstanding point at the
end okay regardless let's see about the
suggestions
um I think we're going to have to do
this in a file
maybe uh maybe not let's may push a
little further
so what I'm going to try to do here is
I'm just going to see if I can get the
sums of all the hyper
parameters okay and this is going to
tell us where stuff collapses I
think
so you can see at the start
here we get um what looks to be pretty
diverse
here now look right here as well so this
is all the
same and then there's like one random
one
here okay I got to be very careful then
looking at this
do o let me think if I can I think I can
do something clever here
so some of
of the last 30 are all the same yeah but
there it's not just one time this occurs
multiple times I want to see if I can
find a pattern so hold on let me let me
get this right um so it's going to be
sum
of OBS equal equal
v
e 2 equals what is this
JavaScript one or
e in
OBS there so basically I'm looking for
Unique values
here um so these are all unique right
and then this one is not unique
here and then we get unique a whole
bunch of uniques
right and then we get a little stretch
here we get two that are not
unique here's another duplicate so we're
getting like a few scattered
duplicates a few like little sections of
duplicates and then we get this giant
stretch here that's all
duplicates and then we get a few unique
points some
duplicates goes back to the pattern from
before and then true false true false
true false it's like
alternating maybe and then false false
false false everything false after that
it mind you these are all recorded as
successes as
well the exceptionally weird thing
we got to look at what outstanding
suggestions
here could the intermediate nonunique
oops just be due to
sum like 32 the end is definitely okay
uh Fair Point
right oh wait wait wait no it can't be
right because it samples all the hyper
prams and some of them are
like you know entropy and stuff those
are continuous
values they definitely shouldn't be
exactly the
down it's samples all every time where
do you see
that I feel like when I look at my run a
lot of them are the
same what can you elaborate what you
mean by
that I don't I don't get what you're
saying just
there lot of work this week brain move
very
slow this might even be a rare toot
Coffee Day
I guess it's an observe here it should
be in this ad observation right
okay so this just depends to success
which is why we have 300 of them but
then it's in get a generate
candidates I thought you said that sum
could not be the same cu the samples
from a continuous distribution but when
I look it does not seem like every each
new every new suggestion samples a new
parameter in each dim really it
doesn't do you have uh do you have data
on this that you can like I don't know
paste a text file or something I would
like to to see that um I generally
wouldn't think that like optimizing one
dimension at a time is smart so I
wouldn't think that they would be doing
that I mean that's like the type of
thing that sounds smart until you think
about it right
unless you have like a hard Independence
assumption and I still think that's not
a good strategy
ah why do it fit outstanding
suggestions.
values so it does fit observations fit
suggestions outstanding suggestions St
so how does stuff get into outstanding
suggestions
weird
Optimizer where the heck does it
actually add stuff to this
H is this not supposed to be length one
is that what's Happening
resample let's see
uh suggest
if it's random sampling then you get a
random
suggestion does it store that yes it
does store
this so it actually will store this
remembered suggestion
where's forget suggestion
though when you observe it you forget
it you observe it you forget
it under what circumstances do you
actually have multiple things in
outstanding suggestions
then when do you actually have multiple
things in the outstanding
suggestions is this even the problem
I mean the thing we're kind of stuck
with is that we
so I guess if the model stops changing
it just keeps suggesting the same thing
over and
the model stops changing
because the success success observation
just has duplicates I
guess um
outstanding suggestions there's one
thing that's probably the same there are
no failures parito group is
constant but this is like chicken or
egg why is it that we keep getting the
same thing over and over in success
well I mean I could just crank up the
random samples at the start and see what
happens I don't think that fixes it
though I don't actually think that fixes
it there's some reason for which the
model is like
I mean I also know that they use this
code for all their language model
stuff so could it just be that there's
some weird thing where like if you
disable resampling and you only give it
one sample at the start it just screws
happening do we want to just like see if
that fixes it to start with cuz it's
been quite a while on this and I haven't
found anything that
like it's kind of circular right it's
like it generates the model collapses
because it's generating one point and
it's generating one point cuz the
model's
collapsed okay I'm going to take a quick
second to clear my head here and then
we're going to we're going to launch
some runs we're going to try their
suggested settings I don't see any
reason why that should make a difference
but you know there's a decent chance
that it does make a difference if
they're using this code for all their
language model stuff
cool okay here's what we're going to do
then is what we're going to do
five now we were getting weird bugs with
this before
but who
knows okay we know what this is going to
be resample frequency can be left to
five default is fine
um num random samples
here is going to
be Len
of ram
spaces so we're going to do one random
sample per
Dimension reasonable enough right
got Atari
here repeat prob of
okay and we're going to
launch new carb
sweep we're going to have to watch this
to see if it actually
works but so far it's
good and as I
said well yeah this is probably a slow
config setting but we still we've got 30
K train on
pong and uh yeah we'll watch this to see
where it goes in fact I think I'll just
leave this up on my other
screen just leave this up over there
just so I can see if it uh starts
erroring and maybe catch that
early so that's
like some progress I would say made on
figuring out what the heck is up with
carbs um
we wanted to do
MOA yeah let's do the Moa one
updated we can launch a new sweep on the
Moa what happened to the MOBA code
this add
uh level
on I should have committed this change
here
demo
we run sweep
cool and now we have our MOBA
training uh of course I'm dumb and I
forgot to update the
metric let's stop
this it's total levels
gained so we're going to update the
metric for the MOBA real
quick this is important because the
current one is not informative is not
allowing the sweep to get any better
over
oops that looks good right we just give
it total levels game and we do config
mooba Luan
cool okay now we have two sweeps
running got Atari currently is training
on the other monitor at 30
7,000 and this is training at
600k and uh we will see whether this is
enough to fix
carbs I Del leave for a sec did you
figure out how to fix the sweeping uh
not for sure definitely didn't fix it uh
figure it out for
certain uh I think that it is possible
that we simply need more random samples
and there's some weird interaction there
so for now what I did is I upped the
random samples to be equal to the number
of Dimensions so it starts off by doing
a bunch of random
trials um and I added a a resample
parameter as well and we're going to see
if that's stable or not and I'll do some
analysis after that but I'm not going to
spend the whole rest of today you know
trying to look for something when I
don't really know for sure what I'm
looking for cuz what I saw so far looked
relatively okay
um a few things I could do from here let
me
think there a few things I could do from
here I do still have this talk to work
on this
video uh I I would say that I could
record the article thing but uh I'm I'm
a too to too tired sounding at the
moment
to do that well so I'm going to not do
that right now maybe if I wake up a
little bit better in the evening I'll do
that so if anybody is interested in
discussing it I'm happy to do that
um there is progress to be made on the
the video for
sure I'm trying to think if there's
anything else I can do immediately on
the Moa
or if we're really more experiment
bound I think we are mostly really just
experiment bound at this point to be
honest
like carbs needs to
be carbs needs to be working in tiptop
shape it needs to not collapse
ever um and then I just have lots of
experiments to run with carbs it's the
main thing for the simulation
update like there are a few other harder
things I can think about um there's the
advanced puffer API that's kind of
non-existent at the moment it's it's
really hacky what you need to do to get
absolute maximum maximum
performance there's that to work on
there's ELO to think
about right those are sort of the harder
things to do at the moment I would
say
um and then there's this
video let me look at this for a second
and just see if I have anything that I
like any insights on
how I want to take this thing and um if
I'm not feeling it I'll do something
else for the time
being I really just want to start like
more simulation Dev to be
honest I haven't seen Noah around lately
I'm curious how his breakout project is
going
in so we have this let me see if I'm
feeling this today if not I'll uh I'll
think of something else to do for the
time
being I mean really I think that the
main bottleneck for reinforcement
learning now is just getting the hyper
pram sweeped good and consistent and
then getting lots of data on the board
for all the environments right
cuz the simulation techniques we have
are good I mean the advanced API needs
to happen at some point
but so how do I doing this now I have
this quick little Snappy intro these are
not final slides this is just like
storyboarding so you know about language
models they learn one way you don't know
about RL it learns another way RL was
superhuman before language models has
real world applications why haven't you
heard of it well it was making a lot of
progress a few years ago until it just
stopped I'm Joseph been working on this
for seven years and this is the RL
Iceberg we start with the sample
efficiency
debacle forcing round pegs into square
coals
okay I want to stress the point here
that language model scale with
parameters where RL scales with data we
have evidence saying that for any fixed
amount of compute RL needs a lot more
data and way fewer parameters to do
well and it just so happens that this is
the setting that we have for most the
things and data sets are limited they
have to be collected but in RL we have
simulations which are essentially
unlimited
data
fortunately you think we you'd think
we'd count our blessings here but uh the
field has really been actively selecting
for algorithms that take forever to run
in order to reduce data usage this
probably comes from
Robotics and since robotics have to run
in real time right they don't have
unlimited data but that's not all of
reinforcement learning so when RL didn't
work in the setting that is not designed
for they moved on to language
models which do work there I don't know
if this is the best way I could make
this specific
point yeah these two slides I don't like
as much here I think I got to rethink
these
infra 900%
overhead yeah I'm not really feeling
doing the presentation thing right at
the
moment really need to be much higher
energy to get
um presentation work done
quickly okay let me think of if there's
a fun Dev thing I can do today that
would like Advance the current state of
uh of
think what would be a fun Dev thing to
do today that's not going to start like
a giant new
project but maybe we'll Advance the
state of puffer lib somehow
I have been trying to figure out for a
while how to put all these things
online how to put the environments
online I could look back at the web
ecosystem and see if I could figure that
out
fun that's very high impact as
well
so let me think about
that the issue at the moment with
putting these things online is that
the simulations
themselves are
in
scyon so we can't really have them
natively they can't really run natively
like that can
they right okay okay I remember the
issue here the issue was
like I think you almost have to be able
to
run Python and
scon in a browser in order to do
that unless I run the environment server
side and then I just send like the
images from the envir
over that is
doable it's a lot of server side work
but I mean if the environments are super
fast maybe
not still have to do key press handling
I think on the client side if they're
going to be human
playable and of course if they're going
to be played by
agents yeah okay I remember this is why
this is a bit of a why this is
that does seem like a fun thing to
build but that seems like that's a
little larger of a project for this
specific
update that would be a scope creep that
would like make this take substantially
longer that seems like that is a bad
idea
yeah that definitely seems like that is
a bad
today I'm kind of in between uh I'm kind
of in an in between phase with puffer at
the moment where it's like I think that
we have like all the core stuff pretty
much exactly the way I want it to want
it to be
but there are like things that need to
be finished
up
and a lot of stuff is like dependent on
waiting for experiments a lot of it's
like experiment bound or at the least
it's very very inefficient to do uh
without waiting on those experiments to
finish we could do some stuff on the Moa
we could do some light stuff on the Moa
for sure though maybe we do that
today um
let me think about that
so I
added yeah because that's like the main
project I think that isn't like that
isn't fully wrapped up outside of
experiments right we're still going to
need to do some stuff on the mooba
so let's see what stuff do I want to add
to this
um or let's let's put it another way
what stuff can I predict that I'm
definitely going to need in the course
of doing experiments for this thing oh I
definitely need the full action space
that's in the other Dev
that I guess I can think about ELO a bit
as
well that's not exactly light work
that's actually quite difficult but it
is the thing that makes the most sense
either the ELO or the advanced API but I
think the ELO is the highest impact or
uh highest impact thing at the
moment yeah
okay
so the issue at the moment the issue
with
measuring policy quality at the moment
right is
that your the the quality is the quality
of your agent is entirely relative to
the performance of other agents
right like there's no like how good are
you at DOTA in the in a vacuum it
depends on how good your opponents are
so the way that you normally handle this
is with an ELO rating
system
um meaning that you have to be able to
play some
games versus
to be able to play some games versus
opponents and then get the outcomes of
those games in order to update your
ELO and this is particularly obnoxious
because you really want to play games
against multiple different opponents
which is multiple different neural
networks
and especially because we need to know
the ELO of your
model uh we need to know the ELO of your
model like as soon as it's done training
cuz that's what WB is going to use for
the hyper parameter
sweeps not to mention that you probably
want this as a metric over the course of
training
I could just add like a I'm trying to
think how complicated it will be to make
like a single purpose
script that does some form of Elo system
the problem is it's going to need some
amount of background processing
right I could do it on spare CPU cores
that's a thought
if I'm going to assume that the mob is
really fast right then I can just do it
on spare on spare CPU course I can just
be running
okay the thing that just bothers me
about this is this is like a pretty
large increase in complexity that is
required for like this one specific
environment though I guess it is
required for
all like all adversarial environments
are going to need some form of
Elo like can I do this in a way
that is not going to make all this
hideously complicated
probably
can probably
curve yeah that's the simplest if we
just keep it very simple right
fast it only needs to be like 15,000
steps per second for
pass in order to be one game per
second so actually I can probably just
do this as like a single additional
process or
whatever all right you know I'm I'm kind
of open to doing this today this would
be uh this is something I've been
putting off it's something that would
help with the the MOBA quite a bit
I'm just trying to think how I make this
like really
start the one thing I'm going to do
before I start on this is I'm just going
to make sure that the sweeps look
relatively
sane okay MOBA sweeps
have wait
what are they already reusing the
same how look at this isn't it just
already reusing the same thing over and
over
again it literally did one run and then
it's reusing the same thing what about
the other
one seven wait
what
pong Z
MOA eight
well
okay I just as I say I'm open to doing
the ELO thing we
find this is using the exact same
freaking parameters
are CU there two separate runs that are
from this
one but all like the subsequent
runs are just from here and holy wait is
this like a huge difference in
performance am I reading this right
this one's the top one yeah wait how are
these
like how are some of these
runs way up
here right and some of them are down
here that doesn't make sense
right is this possibly a carbs thing
that's like wrong
I mean like a w b synchronization thing
that's wrong because like how would this
be how would this be so much better if
it's the same set of hyper
parameters I mean they're running for
the same number of steps you can see
here right
yeah look at this this was like actually
a reasonable loss curve and then this
one ran
for okay I guess we're doing carbs for
now until we fix this and then we're
doing
ELO this is actually kind of good though
I didn't think we were going to get like
such a strong signal so
early okay so we have six point whatever
million steps
same and some of
these make it and some of them
don't episode length keeps going
up episode return
like to have these different runs like
some of them work some of them
don't we can open up the suggestions
right let's go look at the suggestions
in real
time oops
carbs wrong
box need to be on box
eight and it's not
huge okay
so here is we have success observations
starts at
6.7 and then we go to
6.8 and then it gets stuck and all of
these are the
same oh and
then outstanding
observations is
different a little
bit does that mean that it's about to
get uh a
new is it about to get a new
one we'll let it finish running is it do
we have
nine their ninth run
here minus
14 okay it just finished so I should
have this run now now fully
different do I have three lines
now
wait I have a line here that's different
right and then I have the
original this one here that is
different this one
is no this is where they all are yeah
all of them come from here so this the
this is the most recent one okay so the
most recent one is different the most
recent one is in fact
different so somehow the Symmetry got
we did the first run we have cost over
here and
there are multiple things that bother me
with
this well hold on first of
all it's supposed to be
doing uh it's supposed to have a bunch
of random ones first isn't it yeah 14
random
samples so it ain't doing
that right
very clearly it's supposed to have 14
random
samples okay let's let me look at the
code this is leaning towards I did
something really dumb or there's a big
bug in
carbs whatever it is it's substantial I
would think
suggest okay self. is random
sampling return self. getet random
suggestion
get
oops random
sample 32
points basic space to Pam
space suggestions of
base exle around origins in
basic around
Origins there's no seed on here or
something that's going to screw this up
right uh weird functional
thingy oh no it's not bad it's a
categorical do
sample there's no seating so they should
give you something different every time
then there's a mask so we'll we'll
definitely have to check the valid
mask um first though I want to see is
there a chance that I'm just like
totally missing how this
you do suggestion is suggest and then
you update your config with the
suggestion you run this on the
suggestion then you observe input
suggestion output observe value and
cost input output
puffer unless I'm like totally screwing
up a copy or something here right
carb
suggest.
suggestion wait is
this hold
on I don't know what's happening with my
browser there
stuff so when they do this they do
suggestion is carbs. suggest. suggestion
so I have it
right carbs. suggest.
suggestion I do suggestion.
copy it's a flat dictionary so that
should be fine
right and I don't even modify it
observation in Pam which is what they do
right input suggestion output observe
value sugges yeah and then cost is up
time so I'm definitely doing this
right so unless I'm have W be logging
screwed
up
which like no I have this
I can kill this sweep so that I can
start looking through the data
right yeah because like I essentially
know at this point that it's gotten
stuck it can get get itself out but it
shouldn't be getting stuck in the first
place so we'll just kill
this it
B
this okay yeah now I can
scroll
so suggestion is total train steps
are these two duplicate
suggestions yes so
718 here is what I'm going to do I'll
take a screenshot of
this okay and then we'll go down to the
more recent
one these are both within the random
sampling period
and we can see as well that I'm properly
getting back observe values and up
time so this is all running
correctly now this is the latest
suggestion I don't know what happened
here let's try that
oh that's really weird that it does that
okay
so
718 7642 so it suggests the exact same
number of steps
um clip Co coefficient
0367 367 it's suggesting the exact same
thing
right you can even see that the strings
are the same length
yeah everything
is exactly the
same okay so it is actually carbs here
this is actually carbs being
weird carbs is suggesting duplicate
parameters
this so I say print out the
suggestion carbs. suggest. suggestion
um there can't possibly be something
weird with me like accessing carbs
inside of this main function in a sub
process right
thing no because if that were a thing
then I wouldn't
be you know that's that's ridiculous
that wouldn't make a difference
this is just straight up giving me
duplicate suggestions
I mean that's pretty deep in carbs
even why would it be giving you
duplicates well I guess I got no other
choice is important needs to work
all right what we're going to do is
we're going to change Min and
Max and make this a really short
experiment here
250 250k to
500k super short little
experiments let's make it even shorter
than that and make your lives easier
right uh there very short little
experiments should still actually incur
a cost which is all we care
about hey Lucas
welcome we're currently figuring out why
carbs is occasionally giving us like
chains of duplicate suggestions which is
uh
inefficient why it's wasting some of our
processing power before we run like
giant sweeps
okay so we have get random
suggestion this is where this should be
occurring right so then we'll go get
random
[Music]
suggestion suggestions 32
points num sampling attempts so we'll
just go right
here right we just go right there
andari uh mode sweep
carbs back
multiprocessing and yeah we'll see what
this gives
us o
wait will that breakpoint actually
work that breakpoint won't work will it
because we're in a subprocess
[ __ ] yeah breakpoint won't actually do
anything
um God what do I damn it I wish the w b
guys would really like just fix this
thing like there's no reason that that
sweep has to be in a sub process it's so
incredibly obnoxious
process yeah shoot I can't do break
points at all in there can I
okay let let's at least see if we can
debug this
logic yeah right here in carbs.
suggest we should get one right here
right
okay whoa whoa
whoa okay we got lots of
suggestions they look diverse
right this is
like
something they're not duplicates at the
very least
okay it's remembered so we're going to
remember the
suggestion okay so we have
suggestion let's see if this is
deterministic
okay nope we got two different
suggestions
here does not appear deterministic
whatsoever
does this break it just like the fact
that I'm doing a suggestion at the start
like
this no way
right no I was just getting a random
suggestion there's no way this breaks
um hang on I'll be uh I'll be right back
let me just fix the
all right I got some more
ideas I got some more ideas good
evening
welcome I think I have uh I got
something here
like the fact that this is only
occurring in the sub
process is giving me uh is giving me PA
here let's
do this is what we're going to
do we're going to make a new we're going
to comment this entire block and we're
going to make like a dummy main
function uh that's just going to contain
a few key
things okay and then we're going to try
to reproduce it in
there
Main and we're going to do w b equals in
w
b I don't know why it likes injecting
random [ __ ] into my arguments uh
want B.C
okay now we'll
do OBS
out is that in the
demo OBS
out no this is fine
put Okay cool so now we have a dummy
main
function and we get to print the
suggestions out like
this all
right sure we'll run it like
this
and right I have to remove that break
point oh it's 400 p.m. um okay I'm going
to run this and then I'm going to go
make my
shake
okay
suggestion suggest
it's a different suggestion
right different
suggestion wait what is
okay that's
enough so we got
150 23 these are all
unique
150 where's the 150 no no these are all
unique so this does not reproduce
here I got to be doing something weird
right
maybe we add a little bit more of the
original in
here wait what happened with
main oh that's that's garbage when we
worry about
that
so we comment this for now and we go
back to the full main but we just don't
run the
experiment that should be just as fast
in we'll see if it reproduces
then uh observe value is going to be
this and
it's
this
okay
150k believe that's what it was last
time as well so there might be some
determinism
155 226 it's very weird that this does
not reproduce now all of a sudden
I want to make sure that there's no like
weird source of
Randomness 150 it started 150 every time
so there is some sorts of there is some
source
of like seating or whatever for
sure the actual sweeps are deterministic
it looks like or at least the start of
them are
okay yeah there's your start
2305 okay so it's not
stuck it's very
weird I mean I'd assume there'd be some
sorts of Randomness
different okay I'm going to go take a
few minutes to make my
shake um I will be back in a few we got
to figure this out today I mean this is
really the main thing holding everything
back right once we have like no good
high quality consistent carbs
running pretty much everything just Auto
solves so I'll be right
oh I have an
idea just for the
funsies an
idea we had
uh this 10 minutes too eight
runs yep lots of
parameters no big
surprise four individually unique
parameter runs okay never mind I was
wondering if I had uh synced it to W be
wrong but NOP correct
there the thing that's very surprising
to me is the fact that I have num random
samples set to 14 so it should be fully
random and I still got this in an actual
logic is exactly the same but now this
doesn't
Repro does a rofile wait long enough
like I'm out of ideas
I'm just watching the total time steps
and when it pops new suggestions up
155 just seeing if we get
duplicates 226
watching if anything should screw it up
I would assume that it would be having
the same observed value
and up time on every one of them
but no it doesn't look like it's getting
messed up at
odd hi how's it
going welcome back
hesitant we've got a very weird ISS with
carbs where every so often it decides to
sample the same thing over and over for
a stretch is it doing it now wait
253 25399 let's see oh yeah yeah yeah
look it's doing it right now it's stuck
on the same
oddly enough though it didn't uh it took
longer this time but hey a Repro is a
Repro and now it gets out of it it gets
unstuck but still it shouldn't have been
stuck at all
right so why did it just sample the same
thing repeatedly as the question
I also I don't know if you were around
yesterday but I posted the um the
article that I was working on we found
something big with
Atari something very
big no okay I can kill this um yeah I'll
put it in chat
here I updated it quite a bit as
well found a really big problem with the
uh standard Atari setting
here this one doesn't look anywhere near
as bad as the previous ones to be
honest though it is still resampling I
guess
though I positive it was doing it before
on the am
right run
count what the heck is this
let's see this
is Hotel
how about greater
than
55 Okay so
of these points we've got this first run
here and then all of these which fan out
right it literally did one
run and then it did all
I'll check it out in the morning it's
2:24 go get
sleep go
night okay so here
here's our
thing hello
welcome I'm currently trying to figure
out what the heck is wrong with this
hyperparameter tuning
consistent this is
yeah this is totally correct I have all
the settings correct
that how's it possible that it's getting
one
sample and then it's immediately
collapsing and I had this for both runs
and I can't reproduce this
exactly right because I did this right
after where's the pong one
this one here
right 41
minutes you have this one
here and then immediately
after
collapses
how again 14 random
samples I've got to be missing something
right the fact that I can't Repro
this it happened with both
experiments and it's exactly one run
forever
man doesn't play
nice is it the same log locally on wanb
yep appears to be so
so I'll tell you what yeah what's
happening here basically is like carbs
is
working but
every under I conditions that I don't
know why like under certain conditions
it appears that it will have potentially
long stretches where it just keeps
sampling the same parameter over and
over and over and it shouldn't be able
to do that
ever
so I don't know
single node M
yep single
node wanb doesn't ex exactly have great
multi Noe in the first
place so here I was trying to like
without do redoing the training I was
trying to get a Repro and I can actually
get it to eventually crash to the same
thing so I could go from
there I'm trying to think what
information I can even print out
like I don't even know what information
I would look for
I know it can
happen basically anywhere
right cuz it's happened even with the
random
sampling so happened even
just going to comment that initial
suggest I don't think that'll help but
we will
see as the thing is like as soon as we
have this working and we're very like
we're satisfied with this this is just
going to go solve
everything like the environments are so
stupidly fast that good hyperparameter
tuning just like we will solve
everything we can train pong from
scratch in three minutes
is this the same hold on let me see what
you're telling
me move this so I can see this the same
level
problem is the high level problem that
numpy random produces no not exactly no
um I don't know what it is that's
producing the same values like it this
is buried inside of carbs which is the
imbu AI hyperparameter tuning algorithm
I'm using I have the source code for it
but it's like it's a couple thousand
lines worth of stuff in it and what ends
up happening is that the suggestion that
it returns know which is sampled via I
think it's torch technically under the
hood UHA it ends up giving me the same
random values but like I don't know if
it's that it ends up generating a bunch
of candidates and the rest of them get
filtered out so it it collapses that way
or if like somehow it's like cashing a
bad suggestion I don't understand why
but some where it's collapsing the thing
I'm trying right now is I had like this
debug line that I realized I'd left in
where I was getting uh a suggestion at
the start of the program execution so
maybe you're not allowed to like ever
make a suggestion without using it like
maybe it's like a producer consumer
thing where if you forget to consume
something just like random undefined
Behavior happens I don't
know it takes a few minutes to like
repeat anyways it has to get past random
samples in at least in this
wonky I can't wait for this thing to be
like super super solid and stable though
it is just going to shred every
environment out
there I mean you can throw everything
into carbs technically you can even
throw the model size into it they did
that very very effectively at
mbai uh when they were generally
intelligent they solved all of proin
just by doing that big hyper parameter
sweep go
yep there you
go this is now
duplicating
so that's not the uh the reason
unfortunately that would have been
nice that have been a really stupid
reason but at this point I'd be happy
just to have solved
it yeah identical hyper
prems so
can I Repro this outside the damn uh
subprocess that would be a good next
thing to try right
right see if I can Repro it outside of
the subprocess
blah what happened
fast so you're trying to check if WB
sweep subprocess is called
yep I didn't I'm not saying it's a good
idea
but I'm out of
ideas 192
250 2
ah so here we get a warning that I think
the subprocess was
eating so let's see
no candidates choosing at
random well first of all that just
straight doesn't make sense there should
be
maybe it needs too
many or maybe they need to not have the
same um oh no I'm giving it random data
here output up
time so why the heck is it doing
this no candidates choosing at random
runtime warning got divide by
[Music]
0o x. cost numpy log
Z carbs carbs
model he have sucess how is that
possible carbs carbs
right Ren probably outputed zero for up
time uh
allowed input contains did I still not
get it
wait
contains check
array
what okay we're going to try your thing
10 it should be able to have um negative
or zero cost though
looks like you were right about that
though that's not something that's
documented in
carbs okay so now it's going to slow
down a bunch because it's actually using
the fitted
model
uhhuh still giving us unique data
though is this actually some [ __ ]
related to the W sub process
fine could it be something like the RNG
getting
reset okay wait figure me this right
like what if wanb resets the RNG in
every sub process
right because I'm not seeing uh
this doing anything
here okay so let's say I do
did we get it with this one I
forget or did we not get it with this
one
try this one we're going to zero in on
this I bet you it's I bet you it's like
some [ __ ] thing with the
RNG that's my best
bet yeah pray to RNG is this
here Deliver Us from absolutely
cursed [ __ ] that takes all day to do
we'll see if it errs here or if it's in
the other
one should be able to Repro it
here don't know
it is interesting that you can't have
zero cost though
is this not going to Repro outside of
the
full the full thing
yes that is the case for most cost toare
things I think
thing 165 nope that's close but it's not
a duplicate the other prams are
different okay so I I think that we
can't even Repro this outside of the
full the full setting so we'll run that
next
and
um you know it does occur to me
that it does occur to
me I have a few things to try
left yeah a few things have occurred to
me and I think you might have queued me
in as
well
yeah think you might have CED me let me
batch
size that's
fine
[Music]
suggest cool
so this is going to be the
Repro is there
does take a while for it to Repro so
I'll give it a couple
minutes it should Repro I'm expecting
this one to Repro because we have had
this one working
before or repoing before failing before
I should
say and essentially if this
works then
with I'm going to make the cost and the
OBS random
first and then I'm going to mess with
the RNG
I'm starting to become somewhat
concerned though it's not
repoing it's supposed to take like 15 or
so
runs to Repro
I think this is the value on which it
usually
it does not get
stuck
what I was almost positive that's where
it usually gets stuck
23099 I remember that
value so great now we're not even
repoing
this but I don't trust that it's
fixed oh wait is that did it just do it
yeah yeah it just did it unless that's
just a
single resample
no it didn't it's different
now I was a single
resample it's allowed to resample
Once
25 huh
so no longer
repoing which I highly highly doubt
means I fixed
it well what do I do
now if I can't Repro it
obnoxious what are the odds that I think
this is a subprocess
track so
like how the heck is it eat that this
object did you have the resampling Stu
yeah it did I didn't change that stuff
so the thing is I'm wondering I have I'm
doing a weird thing right now where I'm
cheating cuz like I have an inner
function and I'm cheating the carbs
object into it
right that's how I'm cuz technically
it's like a subprocess I'm cheating the
carbs object
into what do I think the odds are that
that part works
correctly but
then like every time it goes to sample
right it relies on internal RNG like
torch RNG probably
um to like ensure that it keeps getting
new random values but if like the one B
every time it does a new a new run if
wanb decides that it's going to fix the
numpy and torch random seating stuff
right that could cause
this I don't know but then the thing is
I wouldn't think it would ever break out
of that
out but I don't know like how else you
would
explain long chains
of same exact hyper
parameters it's so finicky I like I
don't even know if I can Repro this
anymore
well this is actually deterministic
though because this 20 53099 I keep
seeing yeah so I actually remember this
sequence 20 and then 165 yeah I remember
this exact
sequence now this is not going to
um to Repro
anything how would this exact sequence
be
I know I'm going to I'm going to re
place this thing real
quick think this does anything
the fact that in both of the runs that I
did before it literally did one
trial and then it errored
right or then it like went to
deterministic and both of the runs with
different
environments would lead me to believe
this should be very easy to
Repro it's
I mean this is not even a bug that makes
sense to me because I it would be one
thing if the generate function were just
returning like bad
samples but I've also had it where the
random sampler keeps returning a string
of bad samples
like do I just go run the full
experiment and see if it still
exists I don't think that I can even be
reliant on it though it popping up soon
because like in the other pong
experiments it would take a very long
time for it to show up
[Music]
it's better than doing
nothing okay no candidates found
choosing at random is
2008 this also confirms that you do get
this error message this
warning from the sub process so that
wasn't it either this is probably just
the bug that you told
stuck probably this just needs to be
positive here
zero we'll do
this this is
fine do I have to go read the w b sweeps
code I don't even think I can read the
wanb sweeped code right I think just the
API is
seed observe value can likely be zero
yeah I would think so the only other
thing I can think to do is set the torch
random seed to the time inside a
sweep
right I can set the torch random seed to
be the time inside of the sweep and see
if that fixes
it I'm while I'm waiting for this here
you know who's the patron saint of
reinforcement learning research
bad is the patron Saye of reinforcement
learning
research actual footage of what it feels
like doing reinforcement learning
research
right yeah no we're
good [ __ ] okay
well we'll let this to see uh we'll see
if we get the error the other error
but this doesn't seem to be doing
okay it looks like we're good here I
don't see that error and it went away
before when we just set the
uh when we just set the cost above zero
and the cost is always above zero so
we're good here so this is what we're
going to do for
line comment
this this delete this delete this
this okay observe value we're
good and
set torch
and torch seeds to current time
import time
torch
cool let's see what
happens when we
do
yes I think I have the job set to be
super short which I don't know if was
going to
work I should fix this this is going to
not
be yeah we can't have it be this sure
this is not going to give us real
okay b d
there okay so we have that in the
background it's so
wait
what environment steps
okay training time for a single
task normalized
worse yeah it does work it's worse than
wall clock okay
right that model is
huge okay this is chinchilla this is
not RL
starting so how many params did they do
here 1 two 3
case probably we should tune down like
to
I like how
um you can see
here that just increasing the size of
the model
doesn't help with
RL in terms of wall
clock you want more
samples per
compute and the carbs gives you this
very nice tuning result
few games they don't fully solve but
yeah pretty
much parameters for comparison
experiments wait is double descent not a
thing in reinforcement
learning I don't think I've ever seen
it you know what the thing that's a
what's a thing in rein enforcement
learning is models just crashing and
being a pain in the ass and you like
doubling your model size and it's
suddenly not learning and [ __ ] like
that
look we've got our own demons all right
we got 99 problems double disent a
one we're slowly exercising the demons
though does that reflect something about
obiz or
sampling what's the can is there a
canonical reason for double descent
in uh in the rest of ml it's been a
while
test error drops as model grows
larger drop in test to
error wait test error drops
as that's not what it is is
it wait what this is not this is not
what it is right
isn't it it's this
right that drops again like
this is there a reason for
well here's the thing I don't think I
ever saw this in
um this is a big model phenomenon isn't
it this [ __ ] happens in language models
right yeah so here's the thing I worked
in language models before Transformers
were a
thing
um not a great paper but I did do
it I have no idea why this paper has 45
citations that's actually kind of
hilarious
um I guess it's because I wrote some
math and review like people like math
huh
um
and yeah these were my
curves there was no double
descent with the smaller
models and I think that this was like
uh I don't know millions or tens of
millions of parameter model in
reinforcement learning we're using
models that are between like 100k and
like 5 million parameters almost all of
the
time so there you go
we also don't have test sets like that
we have we have unlimited we have
unlimited perfect quality data direct
from the
environment
so no double descent as far as I have
seen there's probably a paper right
well maybe if they make really giant
parameters yeah okay they they did Big
parameters we don't do that
there's actually a there's a paper
that's suggests why you don't need more
parameters this is a fun
paper Schulman
paper they essentially say that
um where is
it they come up with some cool curves
that essentially show that you need way
fewer parameters in reinforcement
learning
for any amount of compute you're going
to
use so I think 10 to the 7 is the most
that they used for like lot of
comput they did
uh so 10 million Max
I get cool
curves do we have um complete
catastrophic failure of neural networks
right complete catastrophic failure of
neuron Nets
compute
[Music]
time 18 minutes
ago no not this
one is this
it all right we got two so far
that's pretty funny how our second data
point here seems to solve
it we get one that's I don't know why we
would get a data point that literally
does nothing that's
oh yeah it did some crazy hyper
parameters that's okay
yeah could be better four minutes to
solve the
environment I think we've seen better
than that
so before it was literally throwing
errors
on yeah okay so now this is actually
three separate sets of hyper prams
and these are fully random
right they look pretty fully uh
random I guess I just let this run and
see what happens
huh it's just very obnoxious because
like I've been spending a lot of time
trying to find this thing and
um like the whole
ability to tune stuff and make this work
kind of rests on having high quality
sweeps
because the goal is going to be that we
do uh sweeps for each
environment and that like that just will
run 500 experiments in a
day or whatever it
takes so we have like one day for
perfectly optimally hyper hyper
parameter tun datari
would be
um do you have it start with the number
of random as yeah I added
that number of random is number number
of Dimensions but it was still failing
before with that which is odd like it
was failing on the second run even with
that I added some RNG stuff which
like if it's getting random data I can't
think of anything other than just
needing RNG
right so hopefully this fixes it we'll
see um that's still like a ridiculous
number of things though to be having to
like having to start with like s random
data points is really obnoxious for
hyperparameter sweep
right
so probably what I'll do is I'll like
tune these a little
bit oh yeah the other thing I was
thinking about right was
um whether I wanted to be able to
initialize okay here this is something
cool that we can we can go through
so starting randomly seems kind of Jank
to me
because like one data point per number
of Dimensions like that doesn't make any
sense right you need
exponentially more data points to cover
the number of Dimensions so what I was
thinking instead is we instead we seed
it with one fixed data point which is
going to be like our current best known
hyperparameters right and then you know
as you run more and more tuning jobs
like it'll just keep getting better and
better because every time you run a new
tune job it'll just start from the best
known current set of hyper parameters
right so you'll always have a good
starting
point
um yeah that's like the main question
for stuff I guess technically we could
have it occasionally do like a random a
random point but
I don't know if it needs like the random
points constantly or not it's kind of
weird let me look let's actually spend
some time breing the
we're interested in maximizing a
function f of real input parameters X
that we observe through a noisy channel
yal f ofx + Epsilon
y zero mean
gaussian
wait we're interested in maximizing a
function f of real input parameters X
cost so much math
generating candidates in local search
defines we serve their T
observations with I par observation as
parameters x
i and the Paro front
is I
in 1 through
T okay so this is saying that this is
the
observations such
that okay this is just this is just math
for Paro cost this is just saying that
either the uh the score you get is
higher than all others uh is higher
than this is this is defining parito
optimality this is just saying that uh
for any point in the Paro front there
are no other points that have um both
higher score and lower
cost that's
all Define the search space I hate this
notation so much for this but I guess
I'm just not used to it it's been a
while since I've done hard
math it's actually perfectly fine set
notation
but poo optimality is a really simple
concept we Define the search space as
gaussian
distributions unnormalized probability
density that's just a
gaussian candidates for the next
suggestion are sampled uniformly from
distributions gaussian centered
at centered at
[Music]
XI from an EV evolutionary
strategies perspective these can be
described as mutations from a dynamic
pool of parents oh okay this is actually
a lot closer to the G to the
um to the thing that I was doing before
then that's
cool we use gaussian Prost process
surrogate to estimate the
cost and output based on the parameters
of each
candidate
huh is standard deviation a
parameter uh yeah I think that there's a
scale
parameter you can specify it
individually for each parameter each
hyper parameter you can specify a scale
we'd have to look at
it carbs uses three gaussian processes
to predict the performance of a
candidate informed by all observations
so
far GPC to predict the cost of a
candidate informed
by predict the Optimal Performance
corresponding to that cost formed only
by the Pito front so
far modeling the shape of the Pito front
used to calculate the
Baseline against which performance is
compared in the EI acquisition function
okay Gan processes annoy me I think that
this is a reasonable model
though probably I could sub this for a
much simpler modeler model and make the
implementation
easier right like I could just get a
correlation of each parameter with run
time and use
that okay they did a lot of fancy stuff
here they looks like they spent some
time
okay so this is something I was
wondering
about um performance improvements on
like models that are run for 10 seconds
aren't as important right so they do
actually have a parameter for
this ooh output variable having an
approximately gaussian distribution
with zero mean and unit
variance parameter trans parameter free
transform is more stable and repeatable
than the Learned parameter transforms
okay that is
interesting though I think that this
solves it I don't think I have to try to
make it more gaussian
resampling noisy observations are
particularly important to handle
correctly for
carbs
yes points on the PTO front are
resampled one out of n
suggestions yeah okay and then Paro
front
minimum because the cost itself is a
noisy parameter the very low cost
observation is usually not very
interesting to
include we start with the best
performing
observations wait because the cost
itself is
noisy the very lowest cost observation
is usually not very interesting to
include so we start
among
20% we start the prto fun with the best
performing optim observation among the
20% with the lowest cost
okay cost really shouldn't be that noisy
though it's really just like setting a
good
minimum parameters like model size can
be
difficult if some parameters o or
whatever
they train an extra model just to see if
something's going to fail I have not
included that yet at the moment but that
is something I will consider
okay so that's a decent overview I think
of the algorithm and all the things we
were looking
at that roughly matches though
everything that we saw there's nothing
super
doing 1 two 3 four five one two three
four five we've got five separate curves
these are fully random it looks like
which they should
be we get all sorts of different
curves this fine
do not like being stuck on
this basically instead of one J yeah
they have
three this is like a very the thing is
when I read this original paper I said
oh this is an awesome algorithm I should
implement it right and then I looked at
the details and went no way right this
is going to be way way way too difficult
this is like the type of thing that they
tuned for three months or whatever until
they got it just right
so instead I uh I went to nups and I
begged them to open source it and they
did the failure one is useful but we
don't have any failures at the
moment so
um puffer has a bunch of optimizations
in the latest version
and we're using like thousands or tens
of thousands of like batch size we have
giant batch sizes basically we store it
all in the GPU we don't even offload it
and it still does
no tldr store your image data as U 8
don't store it as float 32 and then you
have lots of
memory seems really obvious right
well tell that to the other R libraries
funny have you had a chance to look
at navix what's that
one make sure I can grab it from here
right
funny probably don't have to do it in
scon than if it's in
Jack already I was considering doing
this in um in
scon it would be easier
see the thing is I wouldn't be able to
get 670 million steps per second but I
would be able to get 10 to 15 million
per CPU core very easily and um you're
not training on that much data
anyways is it the exact same M or do
they simplify it
new oh no it's not brand new
cool yeah I mean cool
I was thinking of doing this in scon
because it would probably only take me
like it would probably only take me a
week to do the entire thing in scon at
this I don't know if people care though
it depends how many people are already
Jacks this is good though this is good
work fast environments are good I still
think scon is a better is just generally
a better thing for everyone but this is
good I don't know how it's in different
from the xland mini grid Jacks I don't
know
this makes it a little bit less useful
for me to do um my own like mini grid
and puffer
but like if I were to do minig grid and
puffer how long would that be it's got
like doors Keys obstacles that's pretty
much it right in minig
Grid let me
see doors Dynamic obstacles
yeah so probably this whole environment
with all the different configs included
would
be 300 lines of wrappers because I don't
have a proper API and then like 500
lines maybe 600 lines of uh scon like
single file with no other depths
maybe a little more if they have
different observers not much more
definitely at most a
interesting batch typer parameter tuning
this is pretty much what I'm trying to
do
though not thousands in parallel because
like question mark question mark
this we need to see the
um we need to see uh is this Chris L hey
Chris Lou is on here
cool stuff so here's the thing I like
I'm actually kind of doing something
pretty pretty
similar um to this type of stuff but
here's the thing
so I'm not doing batch typer pram tuning
because I think that more complex Ms
need bigger batch size anyways so I'm
just planning on having everything run
large batch which means you just
saturate GPU and you don't need to do
this um
and uh the thing with the Jacks is it
limits the types of environments you can
write so I'm trying to push us towards
high performance but also on complex
environments right minig grid is really
really
simple this is
like minig grid is basically a sanity
check like this is the simplest possible
like environment that you should be
using for stuff so the problem with
Jacks is like when you try to do more
complex stuff that's when it breaks down
this is good on its own though this is
very good on its
own this is just the random portion of
the search and it already solves the M
right
um I guess I'll commit this and then
I'll run the Moa as well just to give me
a more comprehensive test I expect that
this thing is going to crash anyways but
whoops thank you for minimizing all my
windows
I definitely like an operating
system that does the opposite of what it
is named and removes all of my windows
that is very productive
now I don't know where my stuff went
probably here
okay signing off yeah I think I'm about
to just go early as well it's Friday um
I kind of don't have much to do here uh
it's really dependent on the experiment
so I may as well take the uh you know
the little bit of hour or whatever off
and then get to bed
right we got stuck on a bunch of stuff
today
unfortunately could technically go film
the
video it might not be a terrible thing
to do
have system space on
here yeah okay um I think I might just
go film the
uh article video real
quick and uh then I will go
sleep though I might actuallyit wait
until I redo the hyper pram sweeps just
to be
sure I don't know either way I will uh I
will be signing off here uh plan is solo
Dev tomorrow probably back on Monday
hopefully by then we have these
experiments working I'd like at some
point next week I'd pretty much like the
entire research pipeline to be fully
automated so just like the hyper
parameter sweep is so good that it's
like you run it it's fast if it doesn't
work then it's because something is
wrong in the en or whatever that's the
general goal and I'll think about some
things from there but I definitely need
a little RNR so see you and uh star poer
lib if you like any of this work helps
me out a whole bunch we're at 716 Stars
last I checked it's awesome 717 perfect
so go ahead and start this if you
haven't helps me out a whole bunch